olá a todos tanto fala tarde o latitude
pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar que sejam
muito bem vindos
é mais um vídeo e o estrago de que mais
um episódio da nossa série de fayed 7
fredes e hoje pessoal do sul fez uma
atualização e não sei o que é que eu
sentei no novo no jogo mexe ela estava
na versão 1.1 e agora está na versão 1.3
por isso alguma coisa de novo deve ter
então vamos lá só continuar para a nossa
quarta à noite
ok e agora nós vamos voltar a atender o
fórum é que a princípio achei vemos aqui
a cair centro fone não lá não quer
voltar muito calmo é do tipo muito com
ela você pode dizer o mesmo também não
viajou nem sei o que cada vez mais
pronto e ainda lato bom né pronto natal
musical agora no local
ok pessoal eu espero que os com essa
atualização não tenho tido é monstros
novos não mas já falei o pato pronto em
2000 começou agora e já paguei o pato
agora vou ter mais cuidado com o pato eu
já sei que o pato atacando sempre pela
direita e eu sei disso e que é que um z
é que eu usei que dos cortinados algarve
está aberto e que está aberto
assim o r
o clube natal xavier desta vez o
cortinado está fechado o que é bom o que
é esta que ainda continua sem imagem e
outra coisa pessoal é este jogo não
aconteça não tem um acontecimento fixo
ou seja ele é totalmente aleatório
quando vocês perdem uma noite já que o
coelho
quando vocês perdem uma noite nunca
noites que nunca é igual a um ataque
letal pato pataky investir em prática
meu eu ia pisar santo preto
ok só seria tentar muito 30 está
curtindo meus está abrindo se estiver
aberta por conquistar virei meu pronto
quando já voltou pra cá outra vez
ok tal fato pode até ficar aqui enfrenta
meu pai tinha amarelo não pronto eu e
nem deve estar alinhadas às vezes o ok
vamos ter muito cuidado agora está muito
cuidado agora e pelo clube pelos
comentários do vídeo de ontem só vocês
me perguntaram muito dark porque
simplesmente não fecha as portas e fica
à espera porque nós temos bateria
pessoal que neste momento está a 77% e
quando eu fosse uma porta angus da
bateria fica muito maior então eu perco
a bateria toda e isso faz-me perder o
jogo então eu não posso fechar as portas
à toa e só eu só posso fechar quando os
monstros tiverem quase ao pé de mim
porque é esse o objetivo é resistir a
estas noites em que acaba a minha
bateria da nenê de ter muito cuidado do
wec discurso do eu tentei discordou
eu transmito meu eu to atirou mas mesmo
assim o coelho não faz mal por favor e
não eu disse que não por isso eu vou
confiar nela é seu fã
o rei são os pêlos ou mataram este mesmo
estudo que já foi procurador até mesmo
na calçada cortina taq taq quebra no
saque que fica a equipe mas nenhuma
patente a cabeça também agora meu quarto
é muito já mexem com a cabeça tranquila
temos 57 por cento de bateria só vamos
prático carinho até as coisas
acontecerem não é porque não posso estar
a minha bateria toda vai ter que importa
é ver sua obra e seu lançamento que
acontece continua obrigada a assumir o
papel de pai bom agora meu pessoal agora
está aqui ainda
ok já eu já estava lá dentro o bicho
tinha cápsulas e nós temos que ter muita
atenção aqui o bicho eu nem sempre pela
esquerda e quando nós já vemos um espaço
temático chamado na porta e me
explicassem tímida
a música parece uma música e circo
[Música]
terra a questão física mas resta um
baterista sem olhar aquilo camargo estão
ficou muito escuro e agora de repente
não acho que seja preciso calma já
aterrissou em junho não hesita em um
conhecido aqui aqui nem nego netapp
metal prazer pato empatou outra vez
logado
não sendo a questão já três da manhã e
só três foco em horas da manhã na
capital
só que em cima tá tudo vazio já os disso
sai daqui pato sabe aqui para te vejo
aquela boca mel e creep lá para lá os
fatos têm dentes meu melhor para eles
fizeram isso muito conveniente desculpa
para que o estudante quanto eu fui pagar
o pato
ae
é o fato da lei
tony shotwell tac o avanço é primeiro
discurso vai ter cara eu acho que eu vi
alguns jogos do último eu cantar e
encantar natal sílvio salles itaú sa otc
e hospitalar porcentual tocou bateria
20% e isso não pode acontecer meu cão
mark bateria 19% e ainda são quatro da
manhã meu eu estivesse fazendo gastar a
bateria toda está aqui jaz praia também
hoje vai saltar em cima eu sei o seu
silêncio estranho silêncio estranho
silêncio agora está em nós temos quase a
passar esta quarta à noite está muito
silêncio isto andar me iriam andar tinha
nada que o pedrinho
descubra aqui não dá pra falar isso é
muito assustador
não dá muito para o meu coração aberto
que o pai sabia não sabia
aqui tá com uma quebra meu ataque só não
sei se já eram cinco da manhã o site já
não lembro que não quarta noite passada
pessoal vamos ficar aqui então vamos com
a 5ª cia ok pessoal quinta noite
supostamente eu acho que esta é a última
noite porque joguei fight night at
freddy's não é logo sefaz nights
resposta à mente são só cinco noite mas
não vamos agora fazer a quinta noite
adquirir a quarta não é porque vocês
merecem o nosso apoio tem sido muito
calor
o zé manel tufoni já tava lá tutor túnel
audi r8 causa aí o atacou e jacilda que
o pato eo coelho já já assim logo à meia
noite
eu gosto é gosto assim é muito a minha
mãe noite aprontar que o sapato jantar e
e tá aqui ô ô ô zé coelho
olha a câmara já pagou caro até mesmo o
cara tem uma diferença de estranhos
não sei se é vitrine está a funcionar
mal agora eu tô fora eu já não sei nada
senão perto de mim
o jogador não conseguiu porque sua fala
sério não experimentem steel não vejam
os vídeos fiquem só pelos vídeos não
experimentei isso porque está cabo fez
meu está a cabo um coração de uma pessoa
não vamos lá pessoal outra vez quinta à
noite nós conseguimos aguentar até às
duas da manhã
eu acho eu acho que eram duas ou uma uma
coisa por si não é nós vamos lá então
pessoal tentar aguentar e desce do vídeo
o vídeo phone portugal estava a falar
tudo torto e eu quero ouvir agora o que
eu tenho pra dizer ok toca do fone
agora já não toca
senão pouca água
estamos a pouco nos rendeu passos virão
para sempre no fundo de uma lembra a mãe
josé coelho a 14 é que bastou uma
caminhada estado foi sempre o sapato e
os raposas josé raposo e já está fora da
cortina malandro ter cuidado porque os
governos não está como eu tento ficar aí
que edinho te ver ok já que o sequestro
ao senhor pato
o coelho está a lei eo placar estava em
itália o fundo dos olhos dela e ela
escondendo que está fora e só mandar um
cheiro em como como eu vai em da câmera
2 para câmera um tom rápido e uma câmera
com uma câmera do tipo de bicho puto
[Música]
para quem já está próxima de acabar tem
sido aqui meu e detalhe que tentará uma
comissão na hora é essa nossa marca por
vai ter em conta para taxar não é
já silva nascido não posso que estava
trip só não posso após com posso ou não
posso ter sido a porta fechada
aqui o pato
josé raposo de ajuda multinacional por
tim brasil tem que cuidar da economia os
passos de wall street passou aqui mesmo
rápido josé-pa tava aqui embaixo já foi
que brasília é meu eu sou muito rápido
são bonecos muito rápidos o coelho não
acabar a técnico não vai apanhar manel
não mais apanhar porque eu gosto muito
próprio chá portas
venho agora estão à vista
aqui o pacto que o patrão gestor neuly
por possuir simone naquela cabeça meu
timoni os eua mantêm um babaca disse
leite itu além eu voltar eu vou dar alma
à campanha da equipe já está mais perto
está mais perto um dieta mais perto da
itália ainda para fim o papa lá embora
eu não eu a testemunhar a etapa em cima
ela conta apenas o juro que ela conta
apenas o gato ao pessoal eu também
espero que agora eu também perto de mim
agora oitavas precisamente na câmara
estuda mexer ou um olho pra mim isto vai
dar molho vai ser muito de cueca em si
mesmo não pode sair daqui
qualquer detalhe importante é não só
está a ser muito intenção três da manhã
já chamei habitada noite eu acho que não
conseguimos passar mais do que isso por
isso para lá que tu tá giba giba aqui e
ainda este ano embora já se foi embora
assim oral cai na rede estava teria toda
mídia o pato no ataque 33% bateria às
três da manhã eu acho que isto eu acho
que isso vai dar molho de ataque em uma
trilha gasta uma bateria sabe que o top
100 em cada jogadora e mesmo assim
prontas as memórias caiu tranquilo só
vamos aguentar aqui um pouquinho sem ver
as câmeras por nós temos que poupar a
bateria está 28% e são três da manhã
não sei se isso vai contar até o fim mas
não descartou que um cliente de um passo
assim
o filtro
houve outro passo você acha que seu time
mas olha aí eu faço agora eu já se usa
silva apresenta sua lan será a quinta
noite é muito complicada meu muito
complicada não dá e tentará lixado
sempre é isso ok pessoal vamos fazer
isso de maneira diferente como eu não
consigo passar esta quinta à noite eu
vou deixar esta quinta à noite para
amanhã e vou ficar à espera que vocês me
digam estratégias e formas de como eu e
passar esta noite mais facilmente porque
deve ter algum segredo qualquer mas não
saiu a partir das três da manhã
pega um sempre pobres deixem nos
comentários pessoal formas de eu
conseguir passar esta quinta à noite ou
formas mais fácil conseguir agüentar
seis horas eu vi dentro puxado clique
favorito como tem feito nestes últimos
vídeos que estou muito contente mesmo
pessoal
a série é isso só deus à meia noite
fiquem bem e até a próxima
[Música]